voilà des sujets les plus passionnants
on parle de salah lepoko f2 pro qui est
en tout cas un des nouveaux smartphones
de chiens ont mis en france c'est xiaomi
beaucoup d'ailleurs on va marquer
nulle part chez omis sur la boîte
simplement parce que coco et shlomi sont
deux marques séparées sauf qu'en france
tout le monde travaille ensemble et
c'est chez omis poko f2 pro voilà un peu
pour la petite histoire
aujourd'hui à paraître ce smartphone il
nous raconte des choses extrêmement
intéressante par rapport à lui par
rapport au marché par rapport à
l'évolution des smartphones dans le
monde mais juste avant chez un
partenaire de cette vidéo alors petites
coupures
stop aujourd'hui c'est une vidéo qui est
réalisé en partenariat avec sur chaque
sac propose un vpn et je vais vous
expliquer pourquoi est ce qui vous le
faut il ya plein de risques lorsque vous
surfez sur internet et vous données
personnelles peuvent être volés et le
risque est encore plus élevé lorsque
vous êtes dans les wifi public
la solution c'est d'utiliser un vpn pour
venir sécuriser vos données alors à quoi
ça sert un vpn avait peines va venir
créer un tunnel en crypté dans quelles
vont-être toutes vos informations vous
avez donc surfer en ligne sont prendre
absolument aucun risque ça va venir
protéger vos mots de passe vos photos
vos vidéos vos informations bancaires
cartes de crédit ça va venir cacher
votre adresse ip est de vous permettre
de surfer sur internet de façon privée
sécurisé
si vous habitez impayés cas certains
contenus vous n'avez pas accès et bien
grâce au gps vous allez pouvoir le faire
et notamment sand et flix il existe
aussi bien sur mac pc à ios android
android tv linux chrome firefox et vous
pouvez connecter un nombre illimité
d'appareils 105 protège vos données et
tout ce que vous allez faire sur
internet et ils vont absolument réserver
aucune informations vous concernant
ils vont également venir bloquer les
publicités et les malwares et si vous
avez le moins de problème vous pouvez
les contacter 24 heures sur 24 et 7
jours sur 7 ils ont plus de 1000
serveurs disponibles tout autour du
monde pourquoi j'utilise se recharge
simplement parce que je voyage beaucoup
qui a besoin de protéger toutes mes
données lorsque j'ai le connecter à
internet des puits en wifi public et
comme je voyage beaucoup je pouvoir
accès à mon compte à netflix france ou
encore my canal depuis l'étranger très
facilement mais c'est également très
pratique pour trouver des
vion et des hôtels au meilleur prix sans
subir les augmentations tarifaires à
chaque fois vous vous reconnecter je
vous invite donc à venir essayer sur
chaque vous ai mis un code de réduction
qui s'affiche ici vous avez pas moins de
83 % de remise
vous aimez le lien dans la description
on va donc se parler aujourd'hui de
cette jolie petite bête là y'a plein
plein plein de choses à se raconter de
sucre
ce smartphone qui est vraiment
extrêmement mais extrêmement intéressant
mais juste avant si ce n'est pas déjà le
cas vous invite à venir vous abonner
pourquoi parce que je vous parle
effectivement un gain de nouveautés de
smartphones de montres connecter
l'ordinateur de pleine face et je vous
aide surtout vous devinez qui vous avez
le petit bouton rouge la claque
s'abonner alesi actionner la clause
comme ça vous serez au courant
d'absolument tout ça c'est vachement
qu'est ce qui nous dit ce pot coeff de
proue je sais pas si vous vous souvenez
c'était il ya deux ans shi tao me sortez
le poke ophone f1 ont été dans l'idée
vraiment du flagship killer le
smartphone à tarif extrêmement agressif
très performant en france on voit
arriver aujourd'hui le pot coeff de
procès écrit en gros pro ça veut dire
qu'on a le modèle le plus haut de gamme
sauf qu'aujourd'hui on voit que même
chez poko les prix augmentent on est
aujourd'hui un produit qui coûte 5 149
80 x et 599 90 explique t il ya deux
déclinaisons d'ailleurs toutes choses
très très intéressant au niveau de la
déclinaison du choix qui a été fait
technologique derrière mais ça je vous
dévoile à dans quelques instants
mais surtout ça s'inscrit vraiment dans
cette évolution de gamme
on a donc des lianes qui s'élargissent
vraiment entre l'entrée de gamme entre
le milieu de gamme entre les hauts de
gamme et maintenant le très haut de
gamme et c'est la même chose chez
turbine ainsi effectivement là c'est pas
marqué shiomi ses marques et poko mais
malgré tout ça reste la même boîte on
n'est donc plus dans l'idée du
smartphone à 300 et quelques euros on
est sauvés du smartphone à 550 quasiment
600 euros ça nous manque vraiment qui
est une évolution du marché que
l'inondation du marché ya de plus en
plus de produits à tous les prix et une
fois de plus c'est très complexe pour le
consommateur ça l'est également pour les
fabricants et notamment pour xiaoming
qui a pour stratégie d'inonder le marché
avec plein de produits dans chaque
segment prime voilà peu près petite
histoire
alors ce poko f2 croo il est très cool
il fait plein de belles promesses la
première vous avez la voyez bon ben
c'est la 5 0 5 g si vous êtes en france
elle n'est pas encore arrivé mais n'a
pas tardé à arriver donc si vous
achetiez de smartphone vous l'avez au
moins pour novembre vous
normalement pour le début de la 5g en
france la deuxième grosse promesse qui
est là vous le voyez s'il s'est écrit si
highways audio donc on nous fait la
promesse dans audio de haute résolution
on ne le marque également ici weezy
access to avec google apps view the most
une fois de plus je vous l'avais dit
quand je vous ai parlé du midi c'est du
midi ce procès un petit clin d'oeil lien
qui est fait à huawei un petit kahn est
très mignon rouler rapidement pour les
premières qui sont faites et on reste
bien évidemment dans l'idée du trot de
la performance c'est ce qu'on va
regarder ensemble moi la question que je
me pose c'est est-ce toujours un
smartphone c'est à qui est il destiné
est il fait pour vous et sk pouvoir vous
rendre service
oui ou non ici on a smartphones qui est
très cool qui déverrouille extrêmement
rapidement qui puissant qui vraiment axé
sur la performance est en tout cas un
des gros points positifs et on va tout
de suite c'est qu'ici on a absolument
aucune en cochon un écran qui
complètement libéré d'encoches et ça
s'est vraiment bien alors ça on l'avait
sont des smartphones de l'année dernière
notamment chez one place mais ils ont
abandonné l'idée pour venir avec une
petite encoche est ici par contre il ya
un vrai choix qui a été fait d'avoir
cette caméra pop up qu'on retrouve juste
en gros ça chauffe ça vraiment
extrêmement pratique on a un écran
amoled de 6,67 pouces 2400 par 1080
pixels à 395 pixels par pouce avec une
luminosité maximale de 500 dit ça marche
très bien ça fait l'affairé lorsque vous
allez en extérieur vous avez un ratio
vingt neuvième année quand que 92% de la
face avant est un écran est certifié
lutter contre la lumière bleue à leur
première chose que je vous conseille
c'est de venir dans vos petits réglages
vous avez dans votre schéma de couleur
vous restez en automatique ici en mode
par défaut et un peu plus bleu vous
mettez en show c'est beaucoup plus
agréable pour les yeux sont vos attentes
à prendre un petit peu les traces de
doigts devant de toute façon il faut le
protéger avec une coque donc c'est pas
extrêmement grave
on reste vraiment d'alliés de la
symétrie parfaite vous avez un axe
central
ici vous avez deux ronds le premier au
centre avec les caméras le deuxième rang
kef un retour au niveau du flash led qui
est bien positionnée ici au milieu et là
vous avez un x sais pas si vous le voyez
bien on devine au niveau des caméras on
est vraiment solide et de l'asymétrie
c'est bien réussi ça c'est ingénieux ça
marche très très bien
à noter que vous avez un verre corning
gorilla glass 5 à l'arrière mais
également en avant c'est pas le
smartphone le plus léger qu on puisse
avoir puisqu'il fait quand même 2 119 g
on a ici un écran hd r10 plus de bonne
qualité qui sera très bien pour regarder
des séries sur netflix disney + my canal
amazon prime tout ce que vous voulez
youtube et compagnie a noté kissy
faisait pour avoir accès à ces services
en full hd pour toute la partie
visionnage ne serait-ce qu'au niveau de
l'affichage c'est top
maintenant il ya l'affichage pour la
party gaming faut savoir qu'ici vous
avez un taux de rafraîchissement de 60
hertz et non pas de 90 ans ou alors
encore 200 m mais maintenant il ya un
point qui est extrêmement intéressant
c'est la partie audio parce qu'un gros
focus n'a été fait sur packaging parce
qu'ici vous avez un haut parleur mono
qui se situe là se parlera là ne vient
pas du tout travaillé lorsque vous allez
regarder un site d'écouté une série et
c'est bon du contenu multimédia que vous
allez utiliser comme ça ça prend c'est
bien vous avez le son est assez fort
vous avez un très bon steak sa tendance
un petit peu a saturé pour le baisser
pour se soigner
maintenant et c'est là que c'est un peu
moins bien vous avez votre prise jack
vous venez vous le branchez vous avez
donc un smartphone qui est câblé
directement à votre caste et ça c'est
bien mais je trouve qu'ici par contre
vous voyez on a un peu moins de
puissance
je m'attendrais à voir plus alors non
pas qu'il faille pousser à fond pour se
rendre fou vraiment je vous le
déconseille fait vraiment attention à
vos oreilles mais des fois on voudrait
un regain de puissance si vous n'avez
pas un casque qui ferment normalement
vous êtes dans les transports en commun
nous manque un tout petit poil de
puissance et c'est ce que je vais venir
regretté là tu le fais dans votre casque
branché vous avez accès à d'autres
paramètres vous allez dans effets
sonores et vous allez pouvoir venir
activer le jo ici l'audio et fissa
améliorant points mais c'est pas
extraordinaire pour moi ce cas mieux
c'est de venir utiliser les cuiseurs moi
j'ai mis sur rock ça me va très bien
et après vous même de venir régler comme
vous souhaitez vous n'êtes pas mal de
possibilités ça s'est très très bien
vous avez également un ajustement
automatique du volume en fonction de
votre âge c'est pas d'un gaza dire
vraiment poussé les aigus c'est pas
forcément très très beau très très juste
mieux vaut le faire vous avec vos
équaliseur par contre c'est une petite
astuce intéressante s'ils voulaient
venir récupérer en volume sonore vous
entendez pas assez vous pousser ça vous
mettez en 30 60 ça peut vous arracher
les oreilles au niveau de fréquence mais
par contre vous allez en temps un peu
mieux après je peux me connecter aussi
un casque sans fil g du bluetooth 5
points
ok ça marche bien c'est pratique sauf
que ici vous n'avez plus accès à vos
paramètres d quoi l'isr ça ne marchera
uniquement qu'avec un casque filaire et
c'est un peu dommage
vous avez plein de collègues qui vont
bien péter knapp et ex-agent des
appétits ex-compagnie sauf qu'ici vous
n'avez pas dû à albias c'est donc moi
pour l'utiliser avec montceau w/h 1000 x
n 3 mais voyez je reste aussi un petit
peu sur ma faim
ici on trouve qu'il s'est tenue
de performance vous avez un snapdragon
865 et vous avez deux conflits et c'est
là que ça devient intéressant vous avez
soit 6 gigue et un pied drame soit 8
gigaoctets drame sur l'a6 giga vous avez
de la lpddr2 4x tandis qu'ici vous avez
de la lpddr2 cinq mois j'ai aussi j'ai
gardé un missile et au niveau du
stockage vous avez soit 128 soit 256
c'est de lui fs 3.1 et surtout c'est non
extensible ici c'est le dernier
processeur de qualcomm qui est très très
bon et qui nous donne beaucoup de
performances beaucoup de fidélité que ce
soit en navigation que ce soit en
expérience du jeu c'était un des points
forts déjà du poke ophone f1 avec le
popo f2 pro on est vraiment dans cette
idée de la performance
et croyez moi elle est au rendez vous et
ici on a un score se rend au coût de 563
1115 ce qui va le positionner en 5e
position après le 1010 pro après leur
ennemi qu'à 30 pro après les wines site
pro après le milices vous avez donc déjà
trois smartphones de xiaomi dans le top
4 et lui il arrive directement cinquième
position juste au dessus du samsung
galaxy s voix ultra est au dessus du
samsung ace va + 5 g avec des exigences
990 mais c'est également un smartphone
qui est de la 5g et kylie 5g des
smartphones qui va chauffer davantage
donc on a ici du refroidissement grâce
au liquid cool technologie c'est la 2.0
ici on a une très grosse batterie de
4700 milliampères heures et ont
également de la recharge rapide 30 watts
un smartphone qui durent bien dans le
temps l'autonomie est très bien gérée
bien évidemment par le snapdragon 865
vous avez une grosse batterie ça marche
bien ses coups toussa toussa toussa
c'est un smartphone que vous allez
pouvoir regarder entre un jour et demi à
deux jours ça dépend de vous de vos
usages ça dépend ce que vous allez en
faire si vous jouez toute la journée
si vous regardez des films toute la
journée la lumière pousser à fond vous
en douterez vous allez arriver à une
journée en prenant un petit peu mais si
vous avez un usage modéré entre un jour
et demi à deux jours ça ira parfaitement
bien en plus vous de recharger
rapidement grâce à la recharge 33 qui
est inclus dans le smartphone un peu
moins d'une heure vous le recharger à
fond et si le sc mirail pour pau
caussens me why aux bases et sur
l'androïd disent ça marche très bien
vous avez si votre tiroir d'application
ça s'est très très bien tous classés
nouvelle lecture à charge
outil photographie divertissement
communication vous avez tout ça marche
très très très bien néanmois pouvoir
tester me wade 12 il ya quelques jours
c'est vrai que c'est beaucoup mieux
d'ailleurs si vous l'avez pas encore vu
je vous invite à aller voir ma vidéo
découverte de me wade 12 pour la partie
photo vous le voyez vous avez l'arrière
quatre caméras la première caméra c'est
la can à la principale ici c'est un
grand-angle de 64 mégapixels avec le
capteur sony mx 5 186 ici on ouvre à f
1.89 pour trouver juste en face ici au
dessus dans l'angle c'est un ultra grand
temps de 13 mégapixels avec un champ de
vision de 123 degrés avec deux
ouvertures de f 2.4 vous switchez juste
ici en bas vous avez de la macro 5
mégapixels f 2.2 et vous avez ici une
caméra de 2 mégapixels qui ouvre à f 2.4
très pour la profondeur pour les favoris
pour le mode portrait tandis qu'à
l'avant vous avez une caméra de cette
fille de 20 mégapixels qui ouvre à f 2.0
qui est planqué ici voyez et puis un
petit effet quand elle sourd et qu'elle
se ferment et qui est vraiment mais
vraiment très mignonne lieu le choix qui
a été fait au niveau de la photo qui est
extrêmement intéressant pourquoi parce
qu'il vous met un gros capteur de 64
mégapixels za techno 4 pixels en ultra
grand-angle on comprend ça marche bien
mais par contre ici il n'y a absolument
pas de téléobjectifs néanmoins point fr
dans une fois de jusqu'à zoom x 10 il
n'y a pas essayé zoom optique on va
utiliser la caméra principale pour nous
mais dans l'image ça fonctionnera bien
avec le zoom x 2d vous allez monter en x
50 x dit vous allez voir c'est pas
extraordinaire je le montre dans
quelques instants la caméra de
profondeur ce qui fonctionne bien et
qu'on retrouve un peu partout
aujourd'hui donc pourquoi pas mais les
maquereaux de 5 mégapixels j'suis pas
toujours très fan mais ici j'ai été très
surpris par le choix qu'a fait schumi
poko c'est de venir faire travailler sa
caméra de 5 mégapixels
de concert avec le téléobjectif je viens
de vous dire l'instant on n'a pas de
tels objectifs mais c'est quand même
très malade puisque vous avez 24 en
principe à une source interne mégapixels
qui va travailler en mode téléobjectif
et qui va travailler de concert avec le
capteur de 5 mégapixels mais ce qui est
bien par rapport à ceux trouvés
classiquement sur de la macro vous devez
vraiment venir vous collez quasiment un
tout petit distance et déformant vient
toucher les objets c'est des feuilles ça
bouge pas extraordinaire voilà c'est pas
gg là par contre vous restez quand même
une distance qui somme toute assez
correct vous devez vous rapprocher entre
3 à 7 cm de l'objet et vous avez un bel
effet maquereau au point qu'on pourrait
trouver intéressant qu'un peu what the
fuck c'est le fait de pouvoir venir
filmer en 8k 30 images par seconde
l'idée pourquoi pas le sou pour ça sert
absolument à rien vous pouvez bien filmé
en 4k à 30 60 images par secondes et
vous avez une super stabilisation pour
filmer en 1080p à 30 images par seconde
bon pour moi c'est pas un smartphone qui
sert à faire de la vidéo donc on passe
extrêmement rapidement l'a su par contre
est un point qui me gêne un petit peu
sur la photo que je retrouvais vraiment
intéressant que chez omis poko viennent
nos maîtres là dessus c'est une
stabilisation optique sur son capteur
principal ici on l'a pas c'est très
dommage ce qu'on pensait que la caméra
principale serre en plus pour le
téléobjectif donc quand vous venez
zoomer et bien vous voyez les mouvements
et je trouve pas ça extraordinaire en
commande la session de photos par la
caméra de cellfish écoutez je trouve que
le rendu est qualitatif alors là j'ai le
soleil en pleine tronche en un mois de
juin fin juin
donc on a un très bon rendu on continue
avec la caméra principale plutôt pas mal
c'est pas celle là qui va être la plus
intéressante voyez là tout leflux qu'on
assiste un petit flou de bougé à cause
d'un tremblement et c'est vraiment ce
que j'ai reproché si c'est qu'on n'a pas
de stabilisation optique
à côté de ça le pic est bon la
colorimétrie est bonne le résultat pts
qualitatif on passe sur le zoom x 2
passes et bien sûr du numérique
le rendu est bonne qualité fois dix
voiliers occupèrent beaucoup de bruit
c'est vraiment pas terrible
ultra-grand-angle est beaucoup moins bon
c'est assez lisse et caméra principale
c'est très bon une fois de sa marche x
10 pas beau ultra grand angle de caméra
principale à contre-jour ça fait
sensiblement le boulot bien qu'il ya
toujours un petit problème de mouvement
on vient où mes os x 2 on a du détail
c'est bien l'ultra grand temps là contre
jour fera le boulot même s'il n'est pas
extraordinaire caméra principale c'est
très saturé 1 c'est très très vert ici
fois deux fois dix c'est à oublier et l'
ultra grand angle qui fera à la fin
caméra principale calais c'est très
intéressant récupérer tous les taille
des gouttes d'eau fois de on a encore le
détail ultra grand temps que c'est un
peu moins précis et un peu plus saturé
les bras ça fera la sphère et l'emmener
sur la macro et c'est ça qui m'intéresse
vraiment parce que la macro est très
particulière je vous l'expliqué c'est un
mélange du téléobjectif du capteur
principal du 64 mégapixels plus la 5
mégapixels et le rendu est bien et on
est à distance et on a vraiment une
bonne qualité on arrive plus facilement
à faire son point sous ça vraiment pas
mal alors c'est pas parfait c'est loin
d'être parfait mais c'est déjà beaucoup
mieux on récupère mérite tout le détail
c'est un peu brute et mais pas trop ça
va et pour une fois voyez je suis
vraiment agréablement surpris regardez
là tous les petits poils que vous
avait sur la feuille alors il a un peu
de mal mais on va quand même bien tout
ça c'est quand même assez impressionnant
c'est vraiment vraiment vraiment pas mal
regardez-moi la gestion des nuages du
ciel de la lumière on voit la passe à 12
h dr marche très très bien
x 2 ça fait le taff x 10 on oublie x 5 x
et voyez pareil c'est pas extraordinaire
il ya beaucoup de bruit sur la statue
dans le ciel c'est vraiment pas naturel
l'ultra grand temps le frac taf sur des
paysages caméra principale x 2 x 5 c'est
pas terrible fois disent c'est pas beau
et ultra grand temps et un très bien
caméra principale fois deux fois dix
ultra-grand-angle le mode portrait
fonctionne aussi très bien qu'un très
bien des touristes vous avez une grosse
capacité de calcul même entre les doigts
là c'est vraiment le détour et les
cheveux c'est bien des tours et pouvoir
qu'on n'a pas de petit laser on n'a pas
de caméra tough savane le mode nuit et
pas ou faux c'est peut-être ce qui est
un peu en dessous au niveau de la photo
vous aviez un petit bras de lumière qui
passe à travers les volets fermés mais
au-delà de ça pas grand chose et voyez
ben on fera ça me semble ce truc un peu
rigolo s'ébruiter mais bon prince est
extraordinaire ici on a du wifi 6
on a également du bluetooth cinq points
du nfc qui fonctionnera avec google paye
de l'infrarouge pour utiliser leur
smartphone comme une télécommande vous
avez une double sim et pas d'emplacement
pour une carte sd et vous n'avez
absolument pas ici de certification ip
la question du das le das et le débit
d'absorption spécifique on adaptait t20
bien 1789 pour moi tu par kilogramme
inde à ce corps qui est de 1,0 31 watts
par kilogramme et un das membres qui est
de 2,3 117 ou atteints par kilogramme
vous avez donc de config au niveau du
tarif social cadre and +128 giga de
stockage soit 8 gigas de ram plus 256 go
de stockage
la première config coûte 549 euros 90 la
deuxième 599 euros 90 alors verdict sur
ce point qu en f2 pro dans l'ensemble je
trouve bien moins que j'aime beaucoup et
c'est un des points très très fort sur
ce smartphone là c'est qu'ils vous
proposent en 2020 un grand écran en
coche
j'aime beaucoup alors effectivement
c'est au détriment d'une tarification ip
puisqu'à cause de la caméra pop up et
bien vous n'avez pas de certification ip
c'est un choix du constructeur mais en
tout cas je le trouve bien donc il va
être très
mais bon en termes de visionnage on a
une dalle amoled qui est extrêmement
bien maîtrisée qui fonctionne très bien
le jo est pas mal un peu en dessous ça
manque un peu de puissance faut utiliser
quelques petites astuces pour me
récupérer un peu de puissance on a une
machine qui est extrêmement performante
vous pouvez faire un chemin entre votre
technologie de raismes en fonction de la
ram que vous allez prendre 6 lp ddr4 x8
lp ddr5 le stockage est très rapide en
une machine qui est extrêmement
performante la partie photo est aussi
plutôt maintenant qu'on a quelque chose
qui est vraiment très équilibré et je
voulais dit en termes de tarif vous avez
choix entre les deux on a un peu moins
de 600 euros à un peu moins de 600 euros
on a un bon compromis
on est toujours dans l'idée dans l'adn
du flagship qui est leur maintenant il
ya beaucoup de mon temps ce segment de
prix ça devient extrêmement
concurrentiel vous avez besoin de plus
ce qui est un peu plus cher vous avez ri
demi qui est aussi un acteur qui est
très sérieux vous avez beaucoup de monde
il ya aussi des smartphones de samsung
huawei est également présent et bien
évidemment schumi qui vient s'auto
concurrence et donc ça donne beaucoup de
choix aux consommateurs c'est
extrêmement intéressant un meilleur vous
ce que vous en pensez comment vous
trouvez le pot coeff de pro est ce que
vous avez eu le portefeuille f1 et est
ce que vous pourriez vous est ce que
vous êtes déjà laissé tenter par le poke
en f2 pro mark et moi tout ça en bas en
commentaire j'ai hâte de lire vos
commentaires et quant à nous on se
retrouve extrêmement rapidement pour
retirer par l'estac et vous invite à
regarder la vidéo qui suit parce que je
pense que c'est un sujet qui pourrait
vous intéresser pour ce je vous embrasse
mamour beaucoup d'amour et je de rendez
vous extrêmement rapidement à très
bientôt atteint
[Musique]